them thank you
thank you senator enzi senator kane
thank you mr chairman and thanks dean
acosta i appreciated our visit
in your office and appreciate your
public service i think the committee
needs to ask about and i think you're
entitled to respond to an article that
appeared in the washington post online
version last night
and this morning and i'm just going to
read the opening to it i'm going to ask
you some questions because i think you
deserve an opportunity to address it
labor nominee cost to cut deal with
billionaire guilty and sex abuse case um
just first three paragraphs and then
i'll introduce the article into the
record
there was once a time before the
investigations before the sexual abuse
conviction
when rich and famous men love to hang
around with jeffrey epstein a
billionaire money manager who loved to
party
they visited his
to join him at his private estate on the
caribbean island of little st james they
even joked about his taste in younger
women
president trump called epstein a
terrific guy back in 2002 and saying
that quote he's a lot of fun to be with
it's even said that he likes beautiful
women as much as i do and many of them
are on the younger side close quote
now trump is on the witness list in a
florida court battle over how federal
prosecutors handled allegations that
epstein's 64 sexually abused more than
40 minor girls most of whom between the
ages of 13 and 17.
the lawsuit questions why trump's
nominee for labor secretary former miami
u.s attorney alexander acosta whose
confirmation hearing is scheduled to be
in wednesday cut a non-prosecution deal
with epstein a decade ago rather than
pursuing a federal indictment that
acosta's staff had advocated and i'd
like to introduce the article for the
record mr chair
it will be introduced um i'd like to ask
you about this um and first a couple of
questions my understanding is that there
is a pending civil lawsuit
filed by a couple of the
victims in that case
uh seeking to argue that they should
have been given notice uh prior to the
plea deal being entered into is that
your understanding as well um that my
understanding is that there is a pending
civil lawsuit the department of justice
has uh defended the actions of the
office in that matter under both
president bush and president obama's
administrations
the opening that i read suggests that
you
decided as u.s attorney to cut a
non-prosecution deal
that part of the decision was that that
non-prosecution deal be held private not
appear in the public record and there's
an allegation that i just read that
you did not pursue a federal indictment
even though your staff had advocated
that you do so is that accurate
um that is not accurate let me um
let me address the um
you know and the um
you know one of the difficulties with uh
matters before the department of justice
is that um the department of justice
does not litigate in the public record
or in the media and litigates in court
um um i uh let me set forth some facts
this matter was originally a state case
it was presented by the state attorney
to the grand jury in palm beach county
the grandeur in palm beach county
recommended
a
single count
of solicitation not involving minors i
believe
and that would have resulted in zero
jail time
zero registration as a sexual offender
and zero restitution
for the victims in this case
the matter
was
then presented to the u.s attorney's
office it is highly unusual
and as i was speaking to some of your
colleagues um that that have been
involved in in prosecutions they they
mentioned that they don't know of any
cases personally where a u.s attorney
becomes involved in a matter
after it has already gone to a grand
jury at the state level
in this case we deemed it
necessary to become involved
and
we early on
had discussions within the office
and we decided
that
that a sentence or
how should i put this that mr epstein
should plead guilty to two years
register as a sex offender
and concede liability so the victims
could get restitution
and if that were done the federal
interest would be satisfied and we would
defer to the state
that was very early on in the case
i say that because the article goes on
to talk about
a view that the u.s attorney's office
was not aggressive in this matter
can i can i read one one other statement
from the honor federal prosecutors
detailed their findings in an 82-page
prosecution memo and a 53-page
indictment but epstein was never
indicted and then there's a quote quote
this agreement the agreement you
described will not be made part of any
public record the deal between epstein
and acosta says
the document was unsealed as part of the
civil suit in 2015. i'm going to give
you
the senator time to ask his question and
the wit
and the nominee time to answer the
question even though it goes over the
five minutes
um so senator um
uh again to to address your question um
and and i can't discuss the details of
the case but let me take it generally
it is pretty typical
in prosecutions
for an indictment a draft indictment to
be written
that doesn't necessarily mean that that
draft indictment is filed because that
draft indictment does not consider often
the strength of the underlying case
and so as part of any plea
it is not unusual to have an indictment
that
says these are all the places we can go
yet at the end of the day based on the
evidence
professionals within a prosecutor's
office decide
that a plea
that
guarantees that someone goes to jail
that guarantees that someone
register generally
and that guarantees other outcomes is a
good thing and so was that a consensus
decision in your office
it was a broadly held decision yes i'm
over my time mr chair and i'll i may
come back to this in the second round
thank you okay dude
do you feel like you've had time to
sufficiently answer please
mr chairman i i think i have
all right well we can come back to it if
if you'd like to senator uh markowski
thank you for waiting
thank you mr chairman and thank you
mr costa for the time that you gave me
in my office a week or so ago
uh the the issue of job corps has been
raised by